right
any questions comments okay
have i stopped sharing as far as you can
tell still shows you are sharing
screenshots we're still here
now we see you perfect
all right now we're lost
okay now we see you perfect
all right uh questions
comments
yes
so uh wait one second oh come on thank
you
oh awesome thanks so uh
amy in your talk you said
that
one way forward is an algorithmic
approach as to what should be
fun
and you gave examples like what to do
without out liars
i guess my question to to you is a
two-part one the first is what does such
an algorithm look like in your mind in
this kind of
you know meta analysis or you know
wait what is what is the algorithm
what's its what's its goal what is it
doing and then my second question is
given the first part of the talk
why an algorithmic approach
as to one made by ex experts
well so
first one
there are a couple of one of the main
things you want people to do is not
cheat
whether they're doing it consciously or
subconsciously because even people who
don't think they're cheating have the
ways unconsciously they want things to
turn up turn out and that's a very hard
thing to avoid especially with
observational data
um because there's a limit to blindness
for example you can do an observational
data set this
everybody knows
treatment is and so it would be
um
trying to
be systematic
about
cutting off any obvious uh
avenues to purpose to somebody being
able to get the results they want
consciously
or unconsciously i think it's uh
i don't think i have time now to go into
some of the ideas i would have about
doing it um
um but that's the get i mean that's the
criteria the other criteria is to be
sure that um
the methods you're using are methods
that are
under whatever assumptions you're making
would validly
reproduce causal effects if in fact
there were
causal effects i mean you know some of
the things i would do is you know
like um
right many things they're so called
they're doubly in multiple robust
estimators people usually say use a
double or multiple reverse estimator
however which i agree with but however
using estimators
like the g formula that only depends on
the outcome regressions or using uh
things like inverse probability
treatment weighted estimators it only
uses the treatment probabilities i think
it's good those should be reported as
well because
um this has nothing to do with causality
in the absence of the specification all
three have to give the same answer so
even though the doubly robust is better
it would also be nice to know why if if
let's say the inverse probability
weighted estimator was giving a
different answer why it was because that
means there has to be mis specification
essentially in the you know in the uh
treatment probabilities and to try to
understand how that happens and what's
going on so in other words there are
lots of ways
to try to um
look at the data from this many ways
and not just rely on one approach so you
you believe what you did more than you
would otherwise that's all
right thank you
um yeah i have a quick question for uh
roz so uh
so you said you built confidence
intervals for these individual treatment
effects right so and often cause
inference we're interested in either
average treatment effects or conditional
average treatment effects so based on
some covariance that we've also observed
is that something that you can like
incorporate in your approach with a
simple trick on top of that or
is it something so challenging yeah
that's a great question so uh currently
no the simple answer is no we provide
confidence intervals conditional on the
users
and
we don't have joint
uh
confidence intervals across all the
users at the same time so the short
answer is no and we are thinking of like
how to give
confidence intervals on average and yeah
so currently it's not a simple trick on
top of what we have done
yeah so in simple words it's marginal
confidence interval for each user
hi jimmy
enjoy your historical review
about the history so follow up on chris
earlier question i would think that you
agree that this aggressive approach you
also need human in the loop
uh human oversight could you um
elaborate on what type of human
environment you like to see
in this system you wouldn't want it to
run completely by itself
no
i don't that's why yeah that's what i
meant by not completely
algorithmic um
what i would like to see i i think
um
the greatest thing would be
disinterest even more equally important
would be having people really skilled
doing it who are used to seeing
all the ways errors can go wrong
third thing would be not having um
interested parties
doing it which is of course the biggest
problem
in science because
and there are not many mechanisms or
again scientific kudos for having
disinterested
parties um
analyze data
not in a vacuum but with um
input but no control from
uh
subject matter and methodological
experts from each side so again if i had
all the resources in the world
and could get things
they um
organize things as i wish
i think just starting with those things
you could make a huge difference
based on those principles but um i don't
know how to get those principles uh
enacted
what do you what do you think that
i'd like to ask you the same
i definitely agree that an impartial
like third party but then these people
also have to be well trained yes
that doesn't make it's probably
impossible to be completely partial but
at least like
like we said proposals you want a few
degree removed
so that can be done like cannot be
collaborated cannot be formal students
and all of that nothing can be done
and
also there has to be some metric
to for the system to flag because human
cannot be watching all the time so you
have some automation it's like
flag and human investment also probably
a committee
in this oversight
instead of this one person i'll add to
what you said
and also documentation you already
mentioned
that and some automatic algorithm can
also
go through the documents and also do
some natural language processing i would
say
to help to summarize things
more like
human machine collaboration
that makes sense good i agree
any other oh
so
i think it goes to both because you both
talked about so rash you talked about
adaptive experiments and personalized
experiments and generally talked about
validation through trials when we got to
more like personalized affecting
heterogeneous effect estimators
what are your thoughts on validating
through stratified trials for instance
and how can we maybe change our
estimators to target
validation for through such trials and
things like that
all right who wants to go first out
yeah so i
i think you know those are hard
questions because there's
two things they're usually
trials are usually small too small to
document conflict you know
complicated um
choices of
of optimal um regimes i think the best
um
you know i think one of the ways
everybody has a lot of ways of thinking
of um
merging observational with randomized
trials i think
if you do have good observational data
the large observational data set i think
a reasonable thing to do would be to
do your very uh you know complicated um
method of choosing an uh
optimal treatment strategy
hopefully one that
has some interpretability
on the very big observational data set
but don't choose one she was like
down or five and then just run the and
then just analyze those five particular
regimes
as well as the usual you know
everyone take treatment everybody don't
and get their estimate their value
on the uh randomized data
and just see if um a couple of them
are better because i think you can't do
much more with
often the size of randomized trials we
have then they would compare five or six
uh
um you know regimes
so
i maybe use observational data to
choose them and then they may not be the
best but we should get the best of the
five or six you try
this might not be a great answer
i'd be interested in better answers
oh no i i think i agree with what jamie
said i don't have as much experience as
he has so no i think
actually i have a question on the other
end like you said
we need
good trained uh
experts involved in the analysis so that
also
raises the question how do we train good
people right like
in machine learning nowadays we have a
lot of data sets and algorithms that are
widely available and you can see people
learning those in causal influence like
i don't know i don't see that much of
medical records for for obvious reasons
so how do we train good
experts in causes inference like if
the data that are the challenging ones
are not going to be public like do you
have any
thoughts on that or some resources on
that
well i think that de-identified data
needs to be public
i guess i think there needs to be um
competing public competing analyses with
different methods with
criticism i mean it's you know it's the
usual thing you
can't learn how to hang unless you know
when you miss and when you hit the
target
so just
saying i did this method and that's a
good method
ultimately doesn't teach you anything
unless you
find out if you agree with other methods
whether you breed with laters
you know follow-up
studies and science and so forth so i i
i think it's um
you know
this is this is what it means to create
a discipline i guess
thanks any other
questions remarks
okay i have a quick one mostly for uh
jamie but also before us because he's
been in groups and might have a strong
opinion on these things so
um yeah so jamie you mentioned this
multi-world analysis we should different
you should do different ways of
pre-processing use different methods on
the data and then report not just one
analysis but maybe like five or ten
analysis
now i i see a bit of an issue with that
if you think about it from it
there's a there's a decision maker on
the other end might be like somewhere in
politics and they want to see maybe two
or three numbers if you give them 10 or
15 numbers they might eight get confused
or be just like say oh you can't really
say anything so i'll just go with my gut
feeling here so there's an issue with
that our job as a decision is also to
summarize and simplify decision making
and
like where where do you stand on this
like and should we kind of be honest and
just like report everything and add
complexity or should we
simplify i don't know this is open-ended
i don't know
first the example
before i think that's a good question
but the specific example i was saying
well you should do five or six i meant
to offer five or six
hypotheses to the randomized trial where
you know if
if you have the time dependent
covariates and so forth you can estimate
from you know randomized trial data
where you know there was no confounding
i was just saying here five or six
regimes i picked out of an observational
study now run them through the
randomized trial you know
from the randomized trial data estimate
their means under these counter factual
means and
choose the best so that was just a
specific to get one not to two five or
six but the general question you're
asking i don't think there's a simple
answer to it because
i think that
this idea that um
uh we hold all this information that um
you know if we give too much to decision
makers they'll have a problem with
well okay that's probably true on the
other hand
we're almost never in a setting where
other people who are also called
themselves experts
agree with us they'll always be
disagreement so if you
take that strategy
it all is going to end up being
political that is to say they're going
to be competing
um
groups with power and money and they're
going to get the experts they want and
so this idea that there's some
group of experts
who can
talk to one another and say well there's
some uncertainty this is the best thing
to do for a decision maker to decide
is i think
not
realistically you know
poor uh
you know in a politicized um
society like we live
which means it's pretty hopeless but
anyway
good question
question from the chat yep but maybe
yeah i mean i think like it's a great
point and i have been hearing that
again as you said being in bins group it
was very helpful like we have to have a
good communication like you have like
there is stability in the
scientific analysis but there is also
this stability in communication the word
like particular word in one domain may
not meet the same to the other so we
need to have
some kind of simple
understanding like we have to have some
common grounds and for that i think
it needs time and training and we have
to have some simplified pros and cons
list in the language that the people
understand so i think the scientific
community here probably wants to take a
step towards trying to communicate
better like tell them that this is what
we think the study suggests this is the
worst case this is the best case like in
language that a common man will
understand so i think
there is someone in my opinion there is
some onus on us to communicate better
and not
um
to put it like naively live in our own
la la land so yeah
great thanks so i'm now reading a
question from the chat it's a question
for jamie so suppose we have a body of
rcts that are known to be unbiased and
the body of observational studies with
ex-ante
unknown bias what sort of pooling
assumptions do we need to actually learn
something new from the observational
studies
is there in fact value i got a scroll
value in devoting resources to
calibrating observational studies when
rcts are possible
so the last sense was is there in fact
value in devoting resources to
calibrating observational studies when
rcts are possible
i guess
depends a lot on how the rcts were done
my
experience is
that
even if rcts have been
done and they're good ones there are
so many questions that in the next year
two years five years ten years
will arise
about um
specific groups specific
details uh
of how the drug was given when people
took it when they didn't
that um where there won't be data
available
in the trials
as they were running there might be an
observational databases that
there are always
important questions
that
will be left for observational data
to answer because it won't be trial data
but
the fact that there are trials is a
great
advantage because of the
benchmarking to
um
because you better get the question it's
pretty much right that the trials
came with the answers the trials came up
with
before you try to extend them but
but i think
rarely are trials as definitive as the
picture you were
painting just because of the way the
world is
all right thanks i think you have a
question so i just want to see if i have
an intuition about what you're saying
it's more directly i know i
i suppose we can get objectively
qualified domain expert in epidemiology
that works at sandia labs
if
i know that they don't have an
understanding of let's say pinyin
maybe i can develop an algorithm
that will help them evaluate the run
critical trials
of the domain experts
that are definitely good actors who do
have an understanding of opinion
and not help them do their job
that was to me i didn't i couldn't quite
hear it sorry okay well does anybody in
the room know what opinion is
okay well there are people there are
some people in the room that do yeah
right
yes
okay so do you understand why i don't
know opinion i can't analyze a
randomized clinical trial i don't know
it's hard for me to analyze around
critical trial
from a lot of the world's best doctors
that make sense
okay
uh yeah i think we're running out of
time yeah
let's thank our panelists jamie and ross
[Applause]
yeah also thank you very much for the
organizers for organizing everything
today
um yeah what else is there what should i
say
actually cheering
yeah
so um yeah we are all uh set for having
a nice reception outside so please join
us and continue the discussions outside
and tomorrow morning at nine is again
coffee outside and at 9 30 we're
starting in here again
great so see you outside with wine and
food hey are you in birthday